we're skipping ahead adam i'm just going
for 65 one and done
did he just say he's going straight to
65 because
i think he's crazy timeout time out
timeout time out ah
serious bro trying to ice me it's like
105 degrees out here
yo let go here kicking it on another
episode of underrated and today we have
justin tucker not to sound like a heel
but i think my leg puns are
kind of hip here's the kicker that was a
good one too
state farm with their surprisingly great
rates they're our sponsor
but let's get to it justin tucker
because i don't know how someone that
everyone says is one of the best kickers
of all time
isn't a 99. it's time to get my madden
ratings adjuster on the line
call him up jake let's do this
calling madden ratings adjuster
clint let's get right to it justin
tucker how is he not a 99
speak out of your face he's pretty good
but we reserve that elite you know very
rare
99 exclusive rating for amazing
achievements all right time to talk to
the star
justin tucker love this dude jake call
jt calling justin
tucker justin man
this is a good looking fit olive shirt
black legs this is good man normally i
go with like the full johnny cash like
the black on black but it's like 100
degrees here today
all right man uh justin this is clint
oldenburg he is my good friend though at
madden he's gonna hook us up
how you doing man hey i'm i'm good uh so
let's dive right into it
everyone knows that for your position
the two money maker ratings
are kick power and kick accuracy and
everyone
also knows that man has absolutely
disrespected you in these categories
and i can't let this go unanswered and i
know you can't either
yeah man uh you know i know i'm a 98
kick power and kick accuracy
that's what i feel like is completely
disrespectful and uh we've got to do
something about that
clint what yardage does he need to kick
for you to give him a 99 kick power
um i think if we could see him nail one
from you know 65 or deeper
then he might have a case you know what
that's why we're here we're here to
address exactly that
clint this one's a little bit
interesting what about throw on the run
for us i mean i'd love to see both
accuracy
and you know some some starch on the
throw while running at a pretty high
speed
i just need i just need to warm up we
need to get started we need to do this
like right now
all right i can't wait for this one
clint footage coming soon
thank you all right justin i remember
the first fake field goal attempt in
super bowl history
and your name was written all over it my
man and if harbaugh had listened to me
forget the legs i'm using that arm
cannon of yours instead
and that super bowl highlight would look
a lot different so here is how
we're going to improve your throw on the
run rating mr tucker
we're gonna get you that fairy tale
ending you're gonna fake the
run you're gonna roll out to pass and do
you see that target in the back with the
three zones in it
the big money that's that middle zone
you hit that
five points next best is that top one
you hit that upper zone you get
three and the bottom one gets you two
now if you just hit
any part of that target your rating
stays the same
you miss it all together though i hate
to tell you
it's going down because we're only going
to do one actual snap
that we're using for the ratings does
this all make sense
yeah i'm ready for live action
[Applause]
justin tucker at the line of scrimmage
he's setting some guys in motion
tune xm60 outlaw he's
saying interesting words and up he's
moving a wide receiver
but here we go everything on the line
justin tucker and shotgun
takes the snap fakes the handoff rolls
right a lot of speed
corks fires throws
and he hits it oh so close
inches away from five points you know
what i put it all out there and
i'm still so confident still optimistic
listen man i'm gonna get you on a call
with an adjuster later
so you can tell him personally how you
have felt disrespected by madden i feel
like it's only the right thing to do
appreciate the opportunity all right man
i'm thinking we focusing on kick power
shall we you know it's time for the real
deal pressure's on
so here's how we're going to do this
we're going to start you off at 61
and then we're going to move you back
one yard each time you hit the field
goal
for everyone over 65 we're gonna up your
kick power rating
are we feeling confident about this
we're always feeling confident
but uh hey man let's just do this man
let her rip
oh surprisingly great from tucker
ah caught that one a little thin still
good
nice headed to 62.
absolutely destroys it i'm just gonna
kick this one better
timeout timeout timeout time out ah
serious bro
trying to ice me it's like 105 degrees
out here listen
these are real in-game simulations bro
it is hot i am bringing out the ice
all right well we'll just reset and
we'll just knock this down then
this guy is a machine
good and it's good at 63.
man we're skipping ahead adam i'm just
going for 65 one and done
did he just say he's going straight to
65 because
i think he's crazy
holy crap bro you just nailed a
65-yarder without even breaking a sweat
i think we should probably keep going
where are we headed next
i'm just gonna go bombs away from 67 uh
yeah we'll
we'll see what happens then we'll go
from there man he's going for
67. can you imagine
all right here we go ah
crossbar crossbar oh
man you were right on it man all right
[ __ ] it we're done no i said i was gonna
make it i said i was gonna make it [ __ ]
that
i am loving this fire right now
[Music]
hey hey justin tucker from
67. how are you feeling
man i'm just just pissed off it took me
so long
it was sweet to watch uh how does it
feel to be a living legend that should
be honored for all time uh you know i'm
just
i'm just a guy who kicks the ball man
justin i've got your back brother always
clint 65 yards and he's throwing piss
missiles
are you impressed hey i i am impressed
it was it looked like he was breaking a
sweat out there he was working that was
cool
i'm glad that you found that cool
because he found it hot and i am not
letting you reveal your grades
without him being present i'm getting mr
justin tucker on the line let's see how
clint handles the pressure
[Music]
there he is look at him see he's ready
to work out again today
clint hey justin how you doing i hear
that adam has uh
put together a quite compelling case uh
for me so
i'd love to hear what you have to say
clint it's on younow
field goals give me the numbers all
right let's start with the most
important one kik power
justin is going up to a 99 kick power
because he nailed
those kicks on the film that was great i
love it
i love it i'll take 99 kick power all
day every day
clint throw on the run we set up the
targets
what's happening with this rating going
in we had said would have to go in the
target however
he actually throws a really nice ball
but he's gonna go up plus
three to 23 and that puts him as the
fifth
best kicker in the throw on the run
category you can respect it i'll take
what i can get so
uh a three point a three point boost is
is better than two it's better than one
it's better than negative three so i'll
take it okay
clint is justin tucker underrated
justin tucker is absolutely underrated
that's huge
i hope that that three-point boost in
the throw on the run
trait uh will contribute to my overall
ratings increase which i'm eagerly
anticipating
consider your case under review all
right
clint you are the man tucker you are the
man congratulations
on that 99 kick power i love it
and i love you guys for watching thank
you go play madden
with justin tucker's surprisingly great
new kick power rating
and show some love to my people at state
farm for their surprisingly great rates
send them a postcard companies love that
[ __ ] i'm telling you
[Music]
you like what you just saw subscribe to
bleach report on youtube for more
underrated